this also opens the door for a lot of
other characters to actually have their
own shows I finally can get the show of
all the female characters who are the
love interest having a sitcom together
six to eight episodes live studio
audience you get pepper pots in there oh
yeah yeah you get a falcon show you
could get a falcon show you could get a
roadie show you could get a falcon anime
show there the black sidekicks and now
they could leave their own show yeah you
can get gem on hunt zoo in there too you
could have this show with a collector
just that like you could do it like one
of those like History Channel
documentary series likes where he's just
talking to the camera presenting items
or you could do the Heimdall showed your
sublet could finally stop complaining
what I'm hoping for is Marvel is going
to watch this video and go we hire these
guys Groot gardening show gardening show
hey recheck nation it's Greg Albee here
Donald
so before I went to sleep last night
Park before I struggled to go to sleep
last night
I came across this news story primarily
because John Bailey messaged me about it
what is that real and I'm sure enough it
was on every news site her variety
Disney is launching a standalone Loki
Scarlet Witch shows on streaming service
with original actors which sounds neat
sounds like an interesting new step for
those people who have what they want to
do is do these standalone limited series
four characters from the MCU do the
lights are separate just basically four
characters who didn't have an
opportunity to have their own standalone
movie yet or didn't get enough screen
time or or whatever I'm not sure the
decision-making that's going in to these
things and of course then this has
really been confirmed by Marvel or
Disney just yet just because it comes
from a reputable magazine source like
variety doesn't exactly mean it's a
hundred percent true a big part of what
this report is saying that I found
really interesting because I'm aware
that Kevin Feige is not really involved
in the TV shows especially the Netflix
Marvel ones he had a lot of creative
differences with the Entertainment CEO
whose name I have written down here I
per litter but weirdly I'm German
I heard German you're syllables man
reports have always said is like they've
always had creative differences they
don't ever I don't really know that
behind the scenes obviously bottom line
Kevin Feige has never really been
involved those shows that's why you
never hear the MCU ever really
acknowledged those events in the
defenders or I don't even know if they
really acknowledge the agents of shield
stuff but the show's acknowledged the
heck out of the movie incidents the big
green guys go after the big green guy in
the flag waver I wasn't
they're a big part of the stories Kevin
Feige would be really involved with
these specific shows which I am very
much drawn to because it's freaking
Kevin Feige also they want to make them
only six to eight episodes which is a
very common complaint with the Netflix
Marvel shows is how they tend to have
too many episodes I know higher office
recently shortened it down to ten
episodes they still have a certain track
record of doing a certain amount also as
weird as this idea might sound because
you know people like Tom Hiddleston and
elizabeth Olsen because they're
expecting these actors to reprise their
roles as weird as that might sound I
think that's really cool
I personally think that's a neat idea
Tom Hiddleston in Elizabeth Olsen
they're very famous people but this idea
stems from supporting characters who
haven't had their own movies and now
getting their own shows I think that is
pretty neat because these guys are
probably never gonna get their own
standalone movies no it's coming down
the pike Scarlet Witch here we go to get
an opportunity to do a 68 episode series
dedicated to that better than a movie
it's in a lot of way I'm gonna get you
get the character exploration of it I
finally saw the movie Wind River which
made me fall in love with the actress
that is elizabeth Olsen so the idea of
her having her own like 6 to 8 episode
Scott which I'm like well now we get the
chance
skills that we I don't really feel is
truly represented in the film she's been
in and get to see more of her you know
awesome power because that was one thing
that I took away from all the
discussions about infinity war is just
how strong and powerful Scarlet Witch is
and as I yeah how much has not been used
and how long it's taken to get to what
we did see I don't know if this report
means Loki's still alive if this is a
confirmed does that mean Loki's still
alive that's what there was a lot of
argument about on Twitter I saw
yesterday was people going like well
great this is kind of ruining all the
stuff that you just did with infinity
war but you know it could also be a
prequel you never know or something
earlier on the time you watch it pretty
cool hello young Loki what's the pretty
cool adventures of young
Weymouth or or just you know at a
different point in the timeline before
he's dead not nearly a pre gory this
also opens the door for a lot of other
characters to actually have their own
shows which I'm definitely not opposed
to because you know I I finally can get
the show of all the female characters
who are the love interest having a
sitcom together six to eight episodes
live studio audience you get pepper
potts in there you could get the Hawkeye
family drama show we're making bad boy
like he decides to join shield and we go
from that angle you get a falcon show
you could get a falcon show you could
get a roadie show you could get a falcon
anime show there the black sidekicks and
now they could leave their own show yeah
yeah how cool would that be you can get
gem on Honsou in there too
yeah like wacky interplanetary may well
do it every time he flies in on a
spaceship and the ideas are limitless
here yeah man think of it infinity war I
had like 75 heroes in Ursa five heroes
or something and nobody got a ton of
screen time Plus think of all the
characters they haven't made it to the
screen yet oh god that's that's too many
too many Marvel's made too many Marvel's
you could have this show with a
collector just that like you could do it
like one of those like History Channel
documentary series likes where he's just
talking to the camera presenting items
that's not bad you could get the Darryl
show I would actually out love the
Darryl I would be so down for the Darryl
show and I think Chris Hemsworth
wouldn't be opposed to cameo a actually
be down especially you know if these
miniseries are you know you know House
and all that stuff would probably be
pretty easy to shoot an extra scene here
if you continued the Darryl show you can
keep Jeff Goldblum and there's the
Grandmaster kicking it with Darryl on
earth yeah and then like he can play
jazz and stuff like that
like a variety show in your Marvel
Universe what I'm hoping for is Marvel
is going to watch this video and go we
hire these guys yeah because they know
what the audience wants Groot gardening
show good gardening show no one's dead
there's some kind of nature dock with
black panther you know do some kind of
you know like life of lifetime and
really mix up the style you know a lot
of people always complain about the MCU
having Gotha sometimes they seem kind of
similar in their palates and everything
I can really Joker splice here with
genres people want to see the movies in
yeah man totally see that's the thing
feel like my collectors show would be
kind of like the Friday the 13th TV
series we're like he gives you know like
some interplanetary travel or an item
but the items like cursed and stuff and
I guess like a kind of like a Tales from
the Crypt you in the correct way every
episode it's different you know they're
all kind of whimsical and McCobb you can
get the eat really isolated showed he
just really his show he's depressed but
he's also selling like limited edition
like sword replicas QVC kind of thing
you get the Wong show where it's like a
book club our shows are like 10-minute
episodes
hey I mean you know you could do a
fitness show with the normal logic
because like everybody nowadays like in
the Krav Maga and stuff like that you
know get yeah your your dorm lingerie
workout in or you could do the heimdal
showed your cell but could finally stop
complaining as much as I love to keep
pitching these brilliant ideas
don't steal them marvel I don't want the
Netflix shows to leave though they're so
different they're just so much darker
and whenever some report comes out about
these shows a lot of times they they
start going back to the Netflix shows
the thing though is the Netflix shows
have really established their own tone
their own style and even though there's
been a lackluster response to Luke Cage
season two and Jessica Jones season two
and even though iron fist season two is
a lot better for response ain't exactly
your amazing response I mean I think the
better response for that is still lesser
than the not good
but I still wouldn't want them to leave
the Netflix territory even though it's
Disney streaming service is obviously
working towards competing with Netflix
well the best way to compete is to
compete with yourself
yeah that's ready to have a plant inside
there because I mean they're you're
gonna be competing with Hulu as well and
the Hulu Marvel shows also have their
own tone yeah so I what my hope is is
that they can all kind of coexist I mean
I know Disney is kind of a juggernaut
that swallows everything eventually so
you know when Netflix becomes just
another part of just you go together but
from everything I've heard so far the
Netflix shows will stay there and any
other Marvel thing will go to this my
gosh if I get that Hulk show you know
that can actually work cuz they are like
we've we've done the Hulk on TV in the
past and they're always like we can't do
another Hulk movie but maybe yeah a
series could actually be kind of cool I
think Mark Ruffalo would be more than
down just a streaming service yeah you
never see this is gonna be an
interesting experiment too because it's
a Disney Marvel kind of exclusive thing
and like even though everyone's got a
streaming service now I kind of feel
like if anybody's poised to launch and
have it do incredibly well at Disney
Marvel I mean I got it I got to tell you
if this is real if this is really what's
gonna go down I'm sold
I will buy the DS the Disney streaming
like the DC streaming service is
something I'd like to have I do want to
check out Titans and when you guys spare
money and want to see the Batman
animated series remastered yeah you know
it could also catch up on whatever else
this though right here makes me go oh
man just that one I would buy it just to
watch one of those shows just to see
what it is yeah and this could
potentially change the game because at
least what they're talking about sounds
like a pretty high caliber of limited
series here and so we could see bigger
potential for you know movie stars to
come do these you know yeah and have you
know that caliber just in an independent
platform what do you guys think you're
gonna get this Disney streaming service
if this is true or were you already sold
the Lady and the [ __ ]
thing they're doing what John Deere
recently of course I did just enough
research to know there's a lady in the
trash not enough to know what that what
it is exactly and before we close out
this video I wanted to give a special
shout out to a man named Jay T the man
from Hawaii JT we haven't talked in a
while buddy you know sometimes you talk
on messages on patreon sometimes we talk
on Twitter I just want to say man lately
my creative juices have been flowing and
I miss you bud we need to start talking
to each other again
even if it's a private phone call where
I call you with a no caller ID but you
still give me your number I know it's
kind of messed up to you know not go
both ways I'm like only I have your
number but you don't have mine but
that's just the way I am because I'm
very you know self-centered like I think
I'm more important than everyone else I
would call you from a payphone that that
is worth it if you supply the quarters
yes I love you JT sorry didn't really
enjoy the predator but most people
didn't oh why did a mark here you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and check us on
patreon we got TV show reactions Q&A is
a whole bunch of goodies would love to
have me become a patron eject to my own
patreon today